près de cinquante cinq mille cas
supplémentaires de contamination au kovy
c'est le nouveau pic enregistré au
royaume uni ces dernières 24 heures une
hausse fulgurante qui inquiète dans le
pays
le premier ministre boris johnson s'est
exprimé ce dimanche sur la bbc en
évoquant l'instauration de restrictions
plus strictes pour tenter de ralentir la
progression du virus
ce dernier ne cache pas les difficultés
à venir pour un pays qui enregistre plus
de 75 mille morts depuis le début de la
pandémie
il se peut que nous devions faire des
choses dans les prochaines semaines qui
seront plus difficiles dans plusieurs
parties du pays
parmi ces restrictions le cas des écoles
bon nombre d'entre elles resteront
fermés et ce au moins jusqu'au 18
janvier
dans les régions les plus touchées du
pays au contraire dans les zones où les
établissements sont ouverts
boris johnson a encouragé les
britanniques à envoyer leurs enfants en
insistant sur les avantages de
l'éducation et le risque faible de
contamination les écoles sont sur le
risque pour les enfants pour les jeunes
est vraiment très faible pour le corps
enseignant le risque est également très
faible face à la hausse des cas de
contamination 75 % de la population du
royaume uni et des jarres confiné depuis
ce jeudi une décision qui divise les
britanniques c'est un équilibre
difficile à trouver entre l'adhésion du
public au confinement et les dommages
qu'ils causent à l'économie
je pense que c'est un mal nécessaire je
veux protéger le plus grand nombre de
personnes possible et si c'est la façon
dont nous devons le faire alors je suis
en quelque sorte d'accord avec ça les
gens souffrent de la séparation et sont
déprimés de devoir rester à la maison
ils ne peuvent pas aller au bureau pour
travailler le royaume uni entame
aujourd'hui une nouvelle campagne de
vaccination et devient le premier pays à
distribuer le vaccin du laboratoire
britannique astrazeneca pas moins de 530
mille doses sont disponibles à ce jour
plus d'un million de britanniques ont
déjà reçu une dose du vaccin pfizer
biotech